all right let's do some audience
questions we have some really really
good questions this week the first of
which is from Peter Peter said I've
heard you recommend some behavioral
economics books but I know your
background is in traditional economic
can you talk about where you think
reality falls between so-called rational
economics and behavioral economics okay
brilliant brilliant question a
traditional classical rational economics
assumes that individuals and markets are
perfectly and completely rational and
not influenced by cognitive biases by
Framing
by all sorts of other elements which
would lead to non rational decisions so
this would include for example some some
classic examples of this would be if you
ask someone you have two options you
have two bets that you can take you can
have a 52% chance to win $100 and a 48%
chance to win 0 or you can have a 100%
chance to win $50 right the rational
decision would be if you consider the
expected value of that bet would be to
take the 52 percent chance of winning
$100 because the expected value of that
bet is 52 dollars right this is just
simple a probability theory the expected
value of a 52% chance of winning a
hundred bucks and a 48% chance of
winning zero is fifty two dollars per
bet obviously when you have one bet you
will either win a hundred or win 0 but
over time the expected value is $52 the
expected value of a 50% of a hundred
percent chance to win $50 is $50
therefore a perfectly rational actor who
is not influenced by cognitive biases
and heuristics as described by people
like Daniel Kahneman in the book
Thinking Fast and Slow would take the 52
percent chance of winning a hundred
bucks but most of us realize that we
wouldn't do that I would probably just
take the $50 sure bet yeah and
especially
because it doesn't really provide any
insight as to what your financial
situation is so if you're in need of
money then you take the Surefire $50
rather than taking a little bit more
than 50/50 chance at 100 bucks that is
another aspect where behavioral
economics which seeks to address how
people actually make decisions versus
this hypothetical rational actor another
one of the examples that that behavioral
economics has given us is the idea that
money the same amount of money has a
different utility to us depending not
only on our net worth at the time a
hundred bucks has a different value
depending on what your net worth is and
thus you would not actually see the same
decisions made about a hundred dollars
by everybody which would counteract the
totally rational actor what also matters
is whether you're talking about a gain
or a loss of that amount and Daniel
Kahneman's groundbreaking work into loss
aversion is also another way in which we
have seen that behavioral economics
reflects a much more real-world
interpretation of rationality and
so-called rational economic now these
are all super specific examples right
and I encourage you to sort of read and
I'll probably recommend soon Daniel
Daniel Kahneman's book but my view is
the following big picture ok without
just digging into specific examples I
think it's really important as a base to
teach rational neoclassical economics
because in order to again have a better
understanding of how people really
operate it's good to know here's what
the world would look like if people were
completely rational as traditional
economics described it would be more
tough now when I pick up a behavioral
economics book I have a much better
understanding of it because I understand
that this is in comparison to theories
of rational economics if I just jumped
into behavioral economics I would not
necessarily understand why a lot of that
writing is so important and relevant so
I am completely in favor of teaching and
I started my education in economics with
traditional India
classical rational actor Mart stock
prices reflect all known information
blah-blah-blah-blah-blah that that was a
great baseline form but my personal
beliefs now are much more in line with
the behavioral economics work of people
like Daniel Kahneman and Dan Ariely yeah
it's important to keep in mind that
while we may be logical beings to a
great extent I think honestly we're more
impacted by emotions than anything else
so emotions make you feel one way or
another that could completely cook
influenced you to act in a way that's
just not rational there are so many
examples of how framing affects
decision-making if we were perfectly
rational framing would not affect
decision-making and what I mean is for
example people who are told to spin the
roulette wheel okay and after spinning
the roulette wheel they are asked
whether they would pay that amount of
money that came up on the roulette wheel
for a bottle of wine or another example
is with you take your last two digits of
your social security number which are
random right and after talk and then
you're asked would you pay that amount
of money for a bottle of wine and it's
the same bottle of wine those whose last
two digits of their social security
number are a bigger number are willing
to pay more for the same bottle of wine
as people have a social security number
that ended lower numbers there is no
rational basis for that that is priming
or framing and there these are endless
examples so I don't believe for a second
that the rational actors of traditional
economics exist but I think it's
perfectly fine to teach that to start a
foundation for an understanding of
decision-making in the world really
really good question